plein d'histoires pour luca nicolas lau
[Musique]
pour
hier on a ri à gorge des mandats on
s'est marré savait qu'on avait un regard
des blousons ils montent ils m'ont
regardé l'antivol je te jure d'ailleurs
où il vrai tibet ils sont partis en
ville on fouille on fait voler ou frère
je te jure fait pas qu'est ce que j'ai
fait aujourd'hui je suis parti dans la
ruche et créer des fausses couvent
n'ont-ils paul et j'ai demandé aux gens
ce qu'ils en pensent qu'on amènera les
ris avec gérard jugnot des nids sont pas
mal la direction sophie marceau avec
maxime dennis lee dit non mais c'est non
la garde et isa non et on à benjamin et
kelly winn ou non mais jure c'est vrai
mais on ira voir ça dans un an sans
jouer à nantes j'ai hâte de voir c'est
une petite île sans mais quel talent ça
tient le sommet vous verrez que c'est un
jour
visiter la syrie le matin j'avais mon
nouveau bureau mais j'ai pas encore vu
nouveau bureau par la compagnie non je
sais je sais où il est je sais qu'avant
les jo hadji nouveau bureau
j'ai pas encore vu la passe ma règle est
la même la cage où tu vas adorer une
décoration à mon père durable avec de 75
chevaux ça parce que tu as mis en vente
on peut le dire auparavant deux ans
jusqu'à présent je n'avais pas de bureau
je n'ai pas de bureau c'est vraiment la
salle de réunion à sa mesure 1 0 ça
passe ma chambre et là ils ont voulu
nous ont dit bon on va se faire un
plaisir on va faire un bon et ils
mangent ils ont été chercher des meubles
mon frère patron quoi autant dire les
modes mon frère dit le meurice à mon
avis c'est isabelle morini bosc qui leur
a vendu un film quand on veut dire que
vous passez maintenant ça veut dire que
passer dans la journée
il passe tout le monde veut dire que
vous passez dans la journée maintenant
quoi ça veut dire que vous passez dans
la journée est mauvaise on passe tous
les jours j'avais lu tout ça je peux
plus voir s'envoler pour faire flipper
mais le psg vient de proposer 250
millions pour recruter les 24 heures
télé cet été n'a tout ce qu'il fallait
pas rater à la télé ce week end mais
peut-être intervenir dès
[Musique]
dans les jt de france 2 a vu l'enfant
star du célèbre d'un veau d'or est
d'être sheeran terreur est arrivé les
promeneurs du dimanche
exclu 20 45 aussi les images des
personnes qui rendent une soirée chez
gilles verdez selon les médecins il
devrait récupérer leurs facultés
pendant les vacances et thierry beccaro
aux commandes de télématin une deuxième
jeunesse pour titi ça se sent dès sa
façon de saluer les chroniqueurs
sinon tu en as vu kelly cet aprem faire
du roller dans son salon score final 1 0
pour les rollers noter la double blues
dans cette chute ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des petits points jean louis de l'avis
de maxime gagné à participer aux anges
de nrj 12
et pour passer incognito il s'est laissé
pousser les cheveux devant la grille et
matsu jusqu'à
je
ça lui va plutôt bien vu la matière va
bien aujourd'hui que les cheveux courts
mal et mieux c'est cool
comme si ce n'était pas la bonne vitesse
mais c'est ça oui est ce que tu es ce
que tu me fasses contre et kate et moi
je n'étais pas là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi
[Applaudissements]
à ces demoiselles d'arras à barnet
arrivé je me dis juste là on est arrivé
à un stade de l'émission où il ya trop
d'invités tu avais je suis ensuite à la
voix chaude et bordeaux et là tu es bien
témoin à tétouan je suis là mes cheveux
à tout moment et ça j'aime beaucoup
j'espère que ça va être une émission
physique mélanie je suis très content au
pouvoir oui bah c'est ma première fois
c'est très important
ah oui mais non la première fois je
crois que savoir non pas 12 mais savent
ça me fait très plaisir merci merci noël
il est hyper chic sans aimer les deux
sont très bons en mêlée ça parce que moi
j'ai pu la merde alors les deux on
dirait que vous avez une bar mitzvah
d'après-midi pas de se marier mais
ferait autant indirects et le chauffeur
de la barre mais ils ont laissé le doute
son décès nous a étonnés c'est le c'est
pas bien de voler des vêtements fait
réagir s'est passé comme ça merci d'être
là en tout cas on est très heureux
d'être chez
on comprend qu'il a j'aime à témoin et 2
sur m6 où elle qui me donne à lire la
sauvagerie
bien sûr sachez que poète un bon
aventuriers de wayne il faut en avoir
dans la tête comme eléonore cas le don
de nous donner des infos qu'on sait déjà
un peu comme maxime gignac ne gagnait
pas perdu de rigueur rigueur
le tueur s'est pas que de la vente urs
aussi des moments de calme l'occasion
pour emmanuel te faire passer un message
à rennes il visiblement
[Musique]
à sa tête jean s'est tendu je laisse à
d'autres endroits comme ça les gars et
ce week-end nouveau numéro de 50 minutes
inside on n'a pas pu s'empêcher les
visages du sommaire de l'émission ça
paraît presque crédible
[Musique]
kim kardashian fait c'est 37 a
aujourd'hui un nouveau look très bientôt
un troisième enfant un an tout juste
après son braquage traumatisant à paris
matt pokora tamar eux le chanteur vient
de l'officialiser sur les réseaux
sociaux
la story titanic le film phénomène
longtemps après sa sortie retourne sur
l'histoire de ce trou chaque fois qui a
révélé kate winslet et leonardo dicaprio
fille ciel le prince harry et l'actrice
américaine moody's markle son fiancé
mariage prévu en mai prochain qui
réjouit tout le royaume uni et 12 cl et
grandissent émission est con et gérard
d'énergie ou c'est un truc qu'on t'a des
histoires de mes pairs aux gens c'est
déjà dur toute la journée
c'est un truc c'est des grandes
histoires à léontine jl un problème de
concentration j'ai eu pendant les
interviews
c'est ça ou alors elle est une passion
débordante pour les plaques
d'immatriculation mais elle reprend je
reprends des gens c'est moi je ne
surprend pas trop parce qu'elle jette au
courant
s'impliquer le ton va lui j'étais au
courant mais faudra dire à la voix alors
que tex qui dit qu'elles choisissent
bien mais qu'elle en fera parce qu'en
plus ce millionnaire il est intéressé
par le business
jean-marie de saints-anges
le millionnaire franco suisse est en
route vers son prochain boncourt
sophie davant et jean luc lemoine ont
une fille ensemble sophie davant jean
luc lemoine ans retrouvée dans les
questions pour un champion mais mignon
c'est pas très loin des lieux
il réalise comme celle de sa maman et
travaille je suis si asus et l'upa mais
il cesse d'être créatif c'est m'arrête
pas si c'est vrai que tu es un excellent
depuis quoi en 1973 se réinventer d'être
six arrivées de quatre des cinq ans
c'est vrai truc c'est un vrai truc que
j'ai fait c'est important de le partager
avec les gens bref pour comprendre à
quel point cyril hanouna rend les gens
heureux
j'étais manger avec ma grand mère dans
une crêperie à paris et je lui ai rien
dit et je sais qu'elle regarde cheryl
tous les soirs je lui ai rien dit j'ai
dit à sir et vient me voir à la crêperie
il est venu à la crêperie et ma
grand-mère en crêpe du voile était pas
on était en kiff en emmental fromage est
bien là vu cyril est là qui fait dire un
mot elle a vu tu vois et elle m'a dit
mais qu'est ce qui fait la judee venu me
voir l'entreprise et à l'actuel m'a dit
ah ça ça veut dire c'est le showbiz
[Applaudissements]
alors ouais avec l'appui et sa grand
mère je les croise régulièrement
attention ces flux pour sa julie adore
le croisé de trois fois l'autre johann
tschopp a dit non à mais c'est la
réalité
j'ai croisé un seul à peu dit ah non tu
crois que mon autre grand mère malade
j'ai la chance d'avoir encore les deux
grands mères mais je croise
régulièrement que ce soit donc il a tous
ses feux arrière
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai bijou et et tu
la vends du débat oui elle mais elle me
l'a dit je l'embrassé également sa durée
15 minutes je veux faire de ville ces
prêts ont déporté sur le double du
double vitrage
bref tout est bon on embrasse toutes les
grands-mères de keith ballard jamais
plaisir
[Applaudissements]
mystères de l'amour c'est que je regarde
mais j'adore je zappe entre salut les
terriens les mystérieux cartonne à la
série à c'est la série la moins
téléchargé illégalement au monde et
marche sur tmc aujourd'hui et audrey qui
s'est fait péter un massage par une de
ses copines fois vrai moment de détente
de se faire chatouiller entre les
poussines et croyants continuent de
masser grâce à plus tard
[Musique]
avec plaisir avec cécile
akriche et seief et touristes dans le
métro on est tombé sur deux contrôleurs
avec tp particulier c'est rihanna et
d'eric ils font équipe ensemble mais
impossible pour prise qu'à de savoir si
ce sont les vous fait passer son sac
donc dans tous les cas c'est ouais enfin
révélation beaucoup de gens se demandent
comment valérie prépare un brushing
toujours aussi lisse et soyeux et bien
toute seule elle a besoin de personne la
loge elle peut vraiment taper tout juste
avant sa volée ça alors on fait ça est
ce qu'on peut faire ça dans une seconde
par l'ong a dealé pas vraiment et kizad
revient donc il est allé dans la rue tu
as montré découvre je monterai pas la
réaction des joueurs donc on accède à
gérard jugnot valérie bègue on lui
confie souvent ça pourrait le faire
ça pourrait le faire on a donc on à
sophie marceau et maxime guenifi crois
pas du tout je suis ma jama castaldi et
kelly c'est possible ça c'est c'était
déjà le couple paisible alors les
parties voir les gens dans la rue
cette chronique avant le dirai combien
c'est les vacances
le timing semble éluder le masson ben
ouais c'est un kiff là tu fais pas qui
ferait je fais un qui moi aussi je fais
et donc on a montré les images des mots
des fausses photos comme ça avec tout le
temps que j'attends du foie réellement
faire défaut ce couvent
on est allé demander aux gens dans la
rue ce qu'ils en pensaient qu'ils y
croient c'est un truc de fou regarder
ces eaux mais on a filmé paris vous
allez voir tout ça pour montrer donc les
unes qu'on a totalement inventé la
première maxime et sophie marceau
l'idylle l'actrice a trouvé un nouveau
bonheur ah ouais quand même
boxing et ni avec sophie marceau [ __ ]
a dû changer des choses
sophie marceau maxime cugniet
mais moi c'est une guigne os sans qu'ils
n'aient pas vu que tu lis abou madi il
était mais ces mensonges elle connaît
donc vous êtes au courant oui je suis au
courant je les ai vus ensemble il ya
quoi il ya quinze jours
en plus ça me l'a elle même elle m'a
présenté maïmana est très bien normal
[Musique]
alors valérie et gérard jugnot gérard
jugnot
il a choisi la valeur gens ne savaient
pas ce qu'on a fait cas des isa lança
d'organiser ça non gad elmaleh avec moi
me fait jamais surtout avec 50 ans
d'écart l'ademe mal et isabelle anoh me
mets pas mon préféré c'est kelly et
benjamin castaldi il a retrouvé l'amour
pour la dixième fois au stand by et je
trouve que c'est son style de femme un
caddie widow et dit que l a bien peur
surtout pour l'heure pas lyon qu'il y
allait revoir bonjour mes séries se
marieront finir l'année avec 6,7 mariage
habite à la mairie en foot rennais qui
[Musique]
il ya trop mal
[Applaudissements]
j'adore c'est la grande classe
mais après cela il faut qu'ils aillent
habiter